Allora vediamo un attimo che cosa devo
comprare un quadernone a quadretti da un
centimetro con copertina gialla per
religione ma mi avete letto della
copertina gialla per religione ma stiamo
scherzando Ma Nicola non piace il giallo
e glielo prendo blu che è il suo colore
preferito astuccio con Tre matite
ergonomiche triangolari di grafite Ecco
Maria e scrivere Tre matite normali
pareva difficile 24 pennarelli a punta
fine è 12 almeno a Punta Grossa mamma Ma
scusate ma sono bambini o devono
diventare Giotto cosa sono tutti questi
pennarelli punta fine punto grossa un
rotolo di Scottex mamma adesso va bene
tutto ma arrotolo di Scottex ma stiamo
scherzando adesso facciamo una petizione
tutte quante mamme di tutte le sezioni e
chiediamo che la Scottex lametta la
scuola Uh piccolo porta merenda in
plastica Allora io dico con tutto
l'inquinamento che c'è un sacchetto di
carta non va bene